uh
what tv series would you love to guest
star on
oh wow um right now i don't know if this
is like a basic answer
succession i really over the quarantine
i got very into succession
um and i think it's so good and like i
just i'm everything about it i'm
obsessed with it so i would love to be
on succession
i've heard that answer from basically
everyone i talk
joking but it's a lot of evil everyone
loves that show
including myself yeah i was a huge fan
of legion
uh i loved that show how how many how
often do you miss playing carrie
i i miss it all the time to be honest i
i talk about her often i think that
whole
experience that character first of all
was so fun
um and i've learned about myself that
with my work i get very i'm very
influenced like
personally by my characters i think she
was one that
at a time came to me and um gave me a
lot of things that hopefully i
still carry um
but and also just the experience of like
being on legion and like working with
noah and working with everybody who is
there and dan
and bill irwin oh my god i misspelled
everyone so much
it was lovely the thing about that show
for people that have never seen it is
it's a it's a short run with a great
finale and it's one of those complete
series um
so i mean what are your thoughts on the
way the series ended
i thought it was great i love i loved it
i'm really happy
to know that people feel that way
because the whole experience of the show
like what was so fun about it was
the ability that like when we would go
to comic cons or when we would
interact with fans or when i went to
press i would always hear
you know we were i was gifted with
talking to people who care about the
show um
and it was the kind of show that creates
interaction between
like experiencer and creator
so it's not just like you're watching a
show i would say you're experiencing the
story
um so it was cool to be able to like
talk to people who had theories and
and ideas and wanted to see things
happen or didn't want to see things
happen
um but as far as the way the show ended
i feel like i was really
i was really happy i mean i was really
you know i was looking at
the carrie story and i felt like it was
so sweet and
that scene actually with bill and i was
the last uh
scene of the whole show so it was like
it i remember just like sitting on the
floor and looking at him and we had that
moment we touched hands and like
i just every take noah like there was
this weird suspended reality where like
it it was like is this the very last
moment that i'm gonna be doing this
and then he would say go again and i was
like oh god
and then we went and then finally it was
the last one i just remember crying and
thinking it was like so
the experience of it was so lovely and
then watching it i was really happy with
it yeah
jumping into why i get to talk to you
today um what was it about the script
and the story that said oh my god i want
to do this
it was so well first of all my oldest
brother is a real-life iceberg trucker
so that me yeah so that was like super
cool to be able for me to like
pick up his trade for a second i thought
that was super super fun
um and also it just like to me the
character
of tantu is so strong and
um being able to be a young woman
in this group of like big tough men who
are on this mission to save people like
it was cool for me to see
a native woman be the savior amongst men
as well
so it was the care and also i like i
love jonathan hensley's writing and liam
was there and laurence fisher was there
and it was just so many
it was so many cool things i'm a big fan
of liam neeson
and the thing about liam that has been
proven over the last 10 20 years is that
people love
to watch him punch people in the face so
i'm just curious what is it about liam
that people love watching him be a
badass
you know what's funny is that he's so
kind
like he's a very tough guy but he's so
so nice that like i cannot
i'm not gonna say i can't picture him
punching people in the face but i can't
say that i would love to see it now that
i've gotten to spend time with him
but you know what i mean ever since
taken people are falling
you know he just really embodies that
maybe that's why it's his kindness right
like i think we all
want like justness and i feel like he's
such a great embodiment
of what is of like the human idea of
like what is just like he's like big and
strong
but also like kind and tender and you're
like yeah that
like be that do that before i run out of
time with you and i have other ice road
questions but i wanted to ask you um
what are your thoughts on dan
trachtenberg what are my thoughts on dan
trachtenberg
yeah are you a fan of his work for
example
uh yes yeah i saw 10 cloverfield lane
and i loved it
right uh perhaps have you have you guys
been talking about any sort of movie
together
i see where you're going um thank you
very much for that question i'm very
flattered by it but i
but i'm here to talk about the ice road
got it do you think you'll be able to
talk about my question soon
i would love to be able to talk about
all kinds of things soon
uh well i hope that works out because
that sounds awesome if i was talking
about something predator related
jumping back jumping jumping back to ice
road um
you you mentioned your brother actually
is a nice road uh driver how much did
you actually know
about what the movie was going to be you
know what i mean about the ice road how
much did your brother tell you what were
you surprised to know
or learn i knew i mean
quite a bit i knew his experience but i
think to to
step out and really actually learn about
the the trade as a whole i learned a lot
especially about how dangerous it is
like i think he's a
he's a little bit older than me so i
think i was so young when he was
uh i started trucking specifically that
i'm glad he i was so young because i
don't think i feel like we would have
gotten into a fight about it because
once i learned how dangerous it was i
was like hold
on you did this um but it was very cool
he was like i was
like texting him photos i would like
take pictures of the trucks i would ask
him questions like
every day he was hearing from me which
i'm sure was annoying
well the other thing about the job is
that with global warming it's obviously
much
uh much harder to do with a much shorter
window
that that road is open yeah that's very
true and also there
it's funny to talk to truckers about
also like emissions and trucks and the
way that they're changing things and
actually the the solutions there but
yeah the whole
the just concept of actually being on
the ice
um gives it so much less time of the
year he was driving a little bit
he was driving i think a while a while
ago
not that global warming has not been an
issue for a long time um but you know it
feels like it's rapidly changing
yeah it does feel and i gotta go but it
does feel like each year it's gotten
progressively
a lot worse yes definitely save the
planet
yeah completely listen uh uh great work
in this
uh good luck with any sort of alien
movie if you happen to be doing it
thank you for your time thank you so
much